from the New York Post here's a story
that's for some reason is still
happening New York Post the foul mouth
Texas native who was kicked off an
American Airlines flight after a caught
on camera meltdown issued a Maya culpa
on Sunday saying her behavior was
completely unacceptable
um the marketing executive was booted
from the July 2nd flight from Dallas or
Orlando after she accused another
passenger of stealing her airpods and
bizarrely stated that that mother effort
is not real we're all familiar with that
anyway
she's put out this uh statement that she
published on Twitter
and let's just watch him here it is hi
everyone it's me
Tiffany Gomez probably better known as
the crazy plain lady which is completely
warranted
as you know I
have been unwilling to speak on the
viral video but I do finally feel that
it's time
first and foremost I okay first of all
let's just pause it for a second I think
the first problem with this video is
that that's not her okay that mother
effort right there is not real like
that's not
that that's not her right that's not
that's not the same person let's put up
the screenshot from the video
um from the viral video do we have that
okay so there's the person in the video
and I'll go back to the
that's not the same person
am I crazy or is that just not the same
I don't know I don't know who that is I
don't know if that's AI I don't know
what that is but that to me does not
look anything like her
um I don't usually get into the whole uh
body double conspiracy theory thing but
but but uh
well with Joe Biden I kind of buy that
also
um given that the real Joe Biden is like
probably a half dead in a nursing home
right now
but here it just doesn't look like the
same person
so if we can if we could somehow put
aside the fact that this is not even the
same person let's continue watching a
little bit of this video have been
unwilling to speak on the viral video
but I do finally feel that it's time
first and foremost I want to
take full accountability for my actions
they were completely unacceptable
distressed or not I should have been I
should have been in control of my
emotions and
that was not the case
my use of profanity was completely
unnecessary
and I want to apologize to everyone on
that plane especially those that had
children aboard
can't imagine going through that
go back to that screenshot again
that's not the same person
right that's just not that's there's a
two to me these are two obviously
different people so I don't know what's
going on with that but again I I've
tried to put that to the side uh so for
the sake of argument pretending for a
moment
that uh the the person who issued that
apology is the same person that had the
freak out on the plane of course like
the whole I mean the fact that this is
still in the news that they're chasing
this woman down that they're publishing
her name and where she works and her
picture of her house it's like
and now she's giving
issuing the public apology
even though she is actually the victim
here okay yeah she she had a freak out
on a plane she shouldn't have done that
she cussed in front of kids she
shouldn't have done that
but the penalty for that has been
International shame and embarrassment
which which is not a proportional
penalty
and I know we struggle with this these
days but not everything that happens
needs to be
just because something happens in front
of you it doesn't mean that
eight billion other people need to be
involved it doesn't make it relevant to
the entire world
so you can say all you want that Joe it
was her fault she had yes but she had to
freak out in front of a hundred people
on a plane
does that automatically mean that it
should become a national story
when you look into the mirror do you see
dark spots well they're not going away
on their own genu sells Dark Spot
Corrector is here to help with that just
in time for the summer which is really
almost over the Dark Spot Corrector with
not one but three Cutting Edge
ingredients goes to work fast on Sunspot
dark spots liver spots and even old
discoloration both on your face and your
hands you'll be amazed at how quickly
you see results you can now enjoy Summer
Sun Beach and barbecues without
embarrassing spots with genocell you'll
see the results or your money back no
questions asked so go to genyourself.com
Walsh right now get your dark spot
corrector with the new genucel most
popular package say goodbye to those
pesky spots tomorrow they're offering a
free shipping free returns and the best
luxury skin care you've ever used all at
70 off all orders will also include a
mystery luxury gift while supplies last
that's genucel.com Walsh
I think I think she she the penalty for
having a freak out
in public is that you embarrass yourself
okay and but being embarrassed in front
of 100 people is probably enough like
that's you you did something
embarrassing in front of 100 people 100
people uh now look at you like you're
crazy and that's a proportional
punishment and that's the punishment for
what you did uh but instead it it you
know the entire country gets in on the
mockery
to me this is not a proportional uh
penalty which is why she doesn't deserve
an apology you know like I'm always
talented saying about public apologies
this may be one of the perfect examples
of it
um
public apologies as a genre
shouldn't exist
there's there's
almost no circumstance that I can think
of
where where a person
where it's appropriate or necessary for
a person to issue a public apology
the only circumstance I can think of is
when it's a say a politician an elected
representative a representative of the
public who is caught in some sort of uh
corruption or scandal
that actually affects the public
and then therefore yeah you apologize to
the public you have uh betrayed the
people who voted for you you have done
something that betrays the public trust
you've misused public funds you know
something like that
well that involves the public and so yes
you should apologize to the public but
in in almost any other case outside of
that
you don't need to apologize to the
public because the public had nothing to
do with this we were not affected by
this
so Tiffany Gomez if that's really her is
issuing an apology she's apologizing to
me right I'm part of the public she's
apologizing to you
well it's okay Tiffany you do anything
to me I wasn't affected by this in no
way was I harmed by you embarrassing
yourself on that plane I appreciate the
apology in fact I don't appreciate it
like stop apologizing
um
and that's the problem with the public
apologies you're apologizing to people
so you've you've even if you've done
something wrong
you're going and you are making a show
of your uh of your Contrition to people
who are not affected by it
you know one misconception about my
position on this sort of things people
will say that well I you know that I
don't believe in apologizing that I
think no it's not true of course there
are times when you should apologize
you do something wrong you should
apologize you should apologize anytime
you do something wrong
but you apologize to the people that you
have wronged and nobody else
nobody else needs to be involved
okay so if you
um shout at your neighbor and uh cuss
out your neighbor
okay then go knock on your neighbor's
door and apologize to him
but don't come
you know don't walk to some random uh
house five blocks away and say Hey you
know uh I know you don't know who I am
but I cussed out my neighbor two days
ago and I want to apologize to you
why you apologize to them they were not
involved they were not affected by this
they didn't even know about it until you
brought it up
um so public and just because the public
is made aware of something because
everything is public now again that
doesn't mean the public is owed an
apology
so I I think that this uh woman her um
she has long since suffered the
appropriate penalty for
uh freaking out on the plane and
just like go live your life it's that is
it just go just go live just be a person
go be a person and live your life that's
all you have to do now thanks for
checking out this video if you'd like to
listen to my full podcast on the go you
can check out the Matt Walsh show on
Apple podcast Spotify or wherever you
get your podcasts